- [James] I think people have taken to Eli
'cause people in this community
were always looking for
something to be passionate about.
Before Eli came,
we had people that said
it couldn't be done.
But through perseverance,
we won a county
championship in basketball.
- [Eli] I'm Eli Brooks.
My dad has been my
coach for my whole life.
- I'm James Brooks.
I'm the Spring Grove
boys' basketball coach.
- [Eli] My dad started coaching me
when I was in first grade,
when I wasn't even allowed
to play on the Y team.
- [James] Spring Grove is
built around the paper mill.
The community is really close-knit,
passionate about their sports,
but last time we won a
championship was 1971.
(cheering)
They were looking for
something to cheer for.
- [Eli] What I love about
basketball is the teamwork
and the friendships that I made.
Basketball teaches a lot of things.
Treating people the right way,
taking care of the younger
kids that are looking up to me,
making sure my actions are in line
with what my parents have taught me.
Saying goodbye to Spring Grove,
is gonna be hard.
My dad has been my basketball
coach for 10 years now.
I learned so much from him
throughout basketball and
just life experiences.
- [James] It'll be exciting to
see Eli in his cap and gown.
- [Eli] Getting dressed up puts you
in a frame of mind of maturity.
I just want to see the
excitement on my parents' faces
when I walk across the stage.
I'm my dad's child, pretty much,
so that's gonna be tough for him.
We did a lot of things together
that are just, like, everyday things,
but I think he'll miss 'em.
- I think it's important that he goes out
and ventures and shows everybody else
that he is that special kid.
I'm sure me and his mom will cry.
I'm proud to be your dad, um...
You've taken our community
to a place it has never seen.
Why am I getting choked up for the camera?
Share the ball, make good
plays, knock shots out.
(upbeat music)
I'm gonna continue on and coach next year.
Everybody's encouraged on someone local
making it to a big university.
(clapping)
- [Eli] I think that my dad's
coming back for another season
just shows his commitment
to the community.
The ball stops bouncing at some point.
Probably the biggest thing
that you can get out of a sport
is just interactions with other people.
You really have to give
back to your community
what they gave to you.
(beeping)